please welcome professional mentor tater
charles delicious here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm the guy who farts when you shake his
hand i'm the guy who farts when you
shake his hand i'm the guy who farts
when you shake his hand put her there
please to meet ya
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is charles delicious
i am a professional mentor tainor
which is a combination of the words
mentor and
imaginator
i use people's imaginations to help them
overcome their own problems it's
wonderful to be here i believe two
things number one
fool me once
and fool me twice
you stop fooling me
stop it
[Music]
now even though i was born with a rare
condition known as manual specific colon
reflex displacement syndrome
i approach life
with a singularly positive attitude my
attitude is give me the whole gosh darn
kitkat bar
and i think it's important to have
multiple goals many goals in life i
think if you've only got one goal in
life you're probably a professional
soccer player
put her there please to meet you
what do you call 500 lawyers at the
bottom of the ocean
wrong you call it super lawyer aqua
conference
how you doing thanks for coming to the
show
thanks for coming
gross
your hand lotion i mean
sorry i'm late folks i keep getting
stopped on the street people keep
mistaking me for
quadruple daniel day lewis
i was woken up in the middle of the
night last night by a car alarm
then again it might have just been two
women who hadn't seen each other in a
long time
one of them was all oh my god stephanie
and stephanie was all boop
boop
professional athlete roberto salazar
good to have you here you're on my
fantasy baseball team one of the best
short stops in the game right here
ladies and gentlemen the pleasure
i'm a huge fan
big big fan of your work
what do you call a leprechaun that will
suck your for 50 bucks
i don't know about you but i call that
leprechaun a [ __ ]
that's a professional
hooker leprechaun
what did one flamingo
on these synchronized flamingo
masturbation squad
say to the other flamingo on the
synchronized flamingo masturbation squad
just moments after an argument
about their routine
he said
listen
i think we just got off on the wrong
foot
what's that you want to congratulate me
on that joke
thank you so much
knock knock
richard
yes
yes richard who from the equities
research department
very good
he's asian he spells his last name h.u
i'm of the mind that
and that's how i like to start a lot of
jokes
it is of my opinion that
itunes receipts
are a lot like stds
two weeks later you're like when did i
get that
when did i order
the greatest hits of gonorrhea
why did i bother getting the deluxe
version with all the b-sides
why was eleven afraid of twelve
because no because 12 8 13.
oh i forgot to set up that joke properly
i forgot to do the intro to the joke
here's the intro
here's a joke about numbered sharks
there you go
knock knock
doctor
nerds
all right i'm charles delicious ladies
and gentlemen
thank you
thank you so much
i'll be available for handshakes right
at the door here
charles delicious everybody have a nice
hand for charo that is actually andre
duboos here everybody have a nice hand
for andre
dew boucher
[Applause]